you know um last summer
when we started with the george floyd
protests
and we started with the police
accountability movement
some were in the defund the police
movement that wasn't me i was part of
the
police accountability and reform
movement
we started hearing from all sorts of
corporations
we will be mandating all of our managers
do
implicit bias training and at the time i
said and i've continued to
say to me that really is
actual virtue signaling it's actual pr
it's actual optics and there were two
reasons i had
for believing that number one many of
the corporations that were very loudly
saying were going to do implicit bias
training
also had histories of donations to
political candidates
that didn't really subscribe to the
belief of holding police accountable and
dealing with uh racism in this country
etc
um and number two the the other critique
i had of the implicit bias trainings was
that it's not at all clear to me
that training managers at starbucks or
whatever
is really what's going to get at the
root of the problem in the united states
okay that was my criticism
then we now have part two of this as
many of you may know we are now in pride
month here in the united states pride
month where we
um uh uh celebrate and and respect
inclusivity with the uh with regard to
the lgbt community i don't know exactly
what pride
how they name proud pride month i'm just
sort of making this up as i go along but
it's a month about
recognizing diversity and the importance
of equality and respect and etc
and you have companies and this is
there's a great report on this in
business insider you've got walmart
you've got mcdonald's you've got amazon
celebrating pride
after donating hundreds of thousands of
dollars to politicians who voted against
the equality act uh the same
these same three companies amazon
walmart and mcdonald's
collectively donated more than one
million dollars to lawmakers
who voted against the equality act now
in february the vast majority of
republicans in the house of
representatives
voted against the equality act the
equality act was
the goal was to expand lgbtq
protections and if you look at sec
filings you will see that
a lot of the best known companies in the
united states and that includes the ones
i mentioned
donated a whole bunch of money to
politicians who voted against the bill
now most companies donate to both
political parties you look at you know
comcast you look at these big isps
you look at a lot of the big social
media platforms you look at all of it
most of them are donating to both sides
why well it's sort of obvious you don't
know
as a corporation which way the political
wins are going to go
you could get involved and try to get if
you think democrats are better for your
business you could say let's try to get
democrats involved only but then what if
it doesn't happen
you're in a pretty awkward position as a
company that wants to
affect lobbying and legislative power
over uh members of congress etc so
you just donate to both sides and then
whoever wins wins and then you've got
hopefully friends regardless
and this is exactly what is going on
here and
you know i don't mind i think it's a
great thing
if from a marketing perspective it's
better to be pro-equality than
anti-equality right like
put the money out of it for a second if
you just say to me
would you prefer a country in which
saying
we celebrate pride month is good for
business
rather than a country in which saying no
gays allowed
is good for business of course the
country
in which it's more profitable to be for
equality
is the country that i prefer but these
companies
are just doing this for business reasons
in the companies there's no doubt that
you would be able to find
uh homophobic people and people who are
for lgbt rights and
are inclusive and welcoming and for
equality and all of that
but a corporation one of the things
about it is
that it takes on different dynamics than
simply the sum of the opinions of the
individuals who make it up and this is
how you get corporations
that end up doing completely immoral and
horrible things if you
individually talk to the people at a lot
of these companies and say hey
would you ever authorize the known
pollution of a river with carcinogenic
whatever
it'd be hard to find individuals who say
yeah that would be fine with me
but you end up with a corporation where
roles and responsibilities are
compartmentalized and you end up with
corporations
doing things or at least looking away as
things are done that individually many
of these people would not do
much the same way you could have
homophobic
and and uh lgbtq inclusive people at a
corporation and of course amazon does
and of course mcdonald's does at their
stores and of course walmart does
there's no doubt about it
but then as a corporation you would say
what is best for the bottom line and
what's best for the bottom line right
now
is you celebrate pride month brazenly
and cynically from the perspective of
what you really believe as a company
but you keep the money flowing to the
anti-gay
elected officials because the tide could
turn and they could end up
in power now um should you consider this
in deciding whether to do business with
walmart or amazon or mcdonald's
i don't know the answer to that i don't
know the answer to that because
certainly the fact that they're at least
celebrating pride month rather than
taking a homophobic position
is preferable but at the same time if it
really came down to it
and their profits depended only on
anti-gay politicians
then what would your position be what
would their position be
on pride month by the way so i don't
know i i my approach in thinking about
what companies i do business with
is if i'm doing business with a small
business
i do sort of pay attention to you know
if there's three owners there's a
there's restaurants i've found out
have completely xenophobic
owners um and i've stopped going to that
restaurant
with a company like amazon or walmart i
haven't been in a walmart in 15 20 years
or something like that
it's less about the individuals because
there's so many
individuals and i think it's a really
personal decision i don't really have
any advice on that but
the exact same cynicism with which i saw
the implicit bias trainings being rolled
out over the summer and into
early early fall last year we're seeing
the exact same thing from these
companies celebrating pride month
while under uh the table or but not
under the table behind the scenes
donating to elected officials who were
disgusted by the concept of pride month
let me know what you think
about how you decide whether such a
company is one
that you want to give your hard earned
dollars to i'm curious to hear from you
and we'll have more on this on our
instagram account you can find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
if you want to see me at the beach over
the weekend
for a break from politics follow me on
instagram
at david.pakman